by the way my met has an enormous tattoo
on his back that says gangster of love
i haven't seen this tattoo but he's the
gangster of love yeah i mean
i don't even know what he's doing with
that that's like
jd being too bad at like i love mamet
and i think he's really good and
creative and then
and then you see that tattoo and you go
there's something [ __ ] wrong why
would you do that
because gangster of love i don't know if
he's quoting steve miller
or what the steve miller band had you
know he's a gangster
but momet is so obviously not a gangster
of life that's what i'm saying like this
is
not can i explain that yeah explain it
to me i'm what do you mean gangster of
love i mean like of all things to put on
your back
first of all putting let me see your
back lift that up
i don't know if you can it's really bad
i'm ashamed of it let me see
turn around good let me see it shane
well then fred read the show correct
reaction yeah i'm ashamed of it let me
see how big it is what is this what is
he doing
oh jesus christ imagine a girl seeing
him see that
show it to robin don't be a douche show
it to i mean be a douche and show it to
robin
oh that's hysterically bad shame hold it
we're shaming shame
let it shame you for a minute shame
like i thought you were like really
creative and funny and then i see that
like no you can't take your clothes off
something wrong with this guy
why a gangster of love honestly when i
was in the military i was drunk
right we all went to a tattoo parlor
and at the time you gotta understand
like at the time i thought there's a law
against being drunk
and getting a tattoo yeah i i was so
and i saw a gangster of love written on
the wall and it just made me laugh
because of the time i was not you gotta
understand i was getting laid zero
right like a girl wouldn't even touch me
a joke yeah but now like i can never
take my shirt off because people are
gonna think i'm this huge [ __ ]
right well maybe create a bax you're a
creative guy make a backstory up that
actually makes sense like that's kind of
cool say you know when you're in the
military you were
you know you were you were in the first
invasion of iraq or something and like
you know all of us knew that we were
gonna die
the girl's getting dressed and leaving
yeah so we did something funny
i just think of myself talk about like
when you were in jail like it was a way
for you to fit in
because like a lot of the gangs had
gangster of love on there
i just worry about when i'm 80 and i'm
walking around a beach like with my
grandkids and how ashamed they'll be i
just wasn't well
i mean everybody has tattoos and you
know does them to try to look cool and
stuff but
gangster of love is so not cool it's so
not cool not on you anyway
shane no and i just and it's not even
well done it's
it's just awful no yeah no it's thank
you
yeah by the way it's not a great looking
pet too no it's not i would love to get
it covered up
but uh it's like a [ __ ] stamp anyway
yeah
gangster of love yeah it's really really
bad
wow yeah i can never go anywhere and
every time like i get with a new girl i
have to
like explain before the clothes come off
lucky for you
every time there's a new girl it's farm
to between so you're lucky yeah that's
true
change shame shame but shame him
you